what about balance in your life i think
balance
yeah i hate that word yeah me too well i
think especially i do think women get
asked about balance all the time it
makes you kind of insane
yeah i have four kids there's
we don't have any discussions about how
you know mom's not there to pick them up
that's just i think you have to just
make it a
normal part of your day of look i love
all these things equally and so i've
redefined balance probably by a
necessity
of i spend time and energy where i need
to spend time and energy at whatever
that moment of time is and all those
things are equally important to me yeah
and so i don't think my kids think i put
work first work doesn't think i put my
kids first and so somehow i've worked it
out but you just have to
say i love them all and i'm going to
commit to all these things
um and achieve excellence in all of them
yeah you know it's like a cop-out to go
like something's gonna a ball's gonna
drop or something's gonna fail if you
accept that as the world view then
that's just kind of what happens
uh and so the socialist movement here in
america
of uh everything's free uh uh
you're um you're on board for that every
everything free free college free
free rent free free spotify for
everybody free everything
nothing's free exactly i say that all
the time at home
nothing's free yeah i'm actually amazed
though my oldest is 16.
and i would have thought that he would
you know i would have brainwashed him a
little more effectively but apparently
not
because he was honestly advocating for
all student debt
to get erased so i said well who do you
think's gonna pay for that it doesn't
just go away it doesn't evaporate into
the ethos someone actually has to pay
for that
right it's going to be paid for by
taxpayers so then i just started taking
more taxes out of his allowance to say
well i'm just we're going to
collect now for the snack for the
student debt that you are going to pay
off later
yeah it also sends a very weird message
if everybody gets their debt forgiven
that then what does the next generation
do well they're going to be like okay
yeah i'll take debt up to the hill
or get forgiven but i think that's
actually the point i think the point is
to slowly brainwash people into thinking
debt is a great thing because it'll just
go away who cares there's no consequence
to debt
and so then the people who worked hard
so they didn't go into debt are the
fools
and the ones who maximize debt to the
detriment of themselves but to the
benefit probably of governments and
people much power
more powerful than us yeah you know get
to laugh uh it's interesting too because
i think
you know the airline's getting bailed
out constantly and wall street getting
bailed out john the financial crisis
really gave people this upper hand to
say well you're bailing out rich
powerful people therefore we might need
to
have bailout culture and we don't need
bailout culture we need accountability
culture and we shouldn't have bailed out
wall street we should have let a couple
of ba and a couple banks did fail in
fairness
but this idea i was talking to to name
drop richard branson about like
uh all the airlines getting bailed out
and it's like yeah if you're a new
airline you have to make it and if
you're one of these old airlines with
pensions or whatever they just bail you
out over and over again
and you're like why does the service on
united and delta suck it's like
because all they do is work for the
bailout yeah and i don't think
enough americans appreciate that they're
the ones that bailed them out right it
all
gets it all gets passed on to them in
terms of higher prices all right
but i do want to say one thing which is
i don't think millennials are
as bad as people think agreed and i have
found
that people are really just looking for
more meaning like there's almost like a
they're a misunderstood generation which
is they decided money was not the thing
so they've got these phrases that we
might have an allergic reaction to but
at the end of the day what they're
saying is
i want my time to matter so they
actually end up being some of the best
employees because
once they commit to sort of a purpose
and a cause they really are all in
yeah that makes total sense right the
entitlement we you see entitlement
and what they're really saying is if i'm
gonna give my life to this it better
be there better be some substance here
that's right right and if i'm not going
to yeah of course i want to get the
entitlements
right if i'm punching a clock yeah okay
let's have the negotiation i'll take all
the entitlements you can give her
give me but if not yeah if i find
purpose then i'm going to sacrifice and
they do sacrifice massively they
absolutely do
if it's something they believe in